[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Whether it's pizza, pie,
or anything else
round, you can't
calculate the circumference
without knowing
about 3.14, also known as pi.
But there's a few
more digits than that.
So let's talk to Emma and see
how she broke the world record
for calculating 31.4 trillion
digits using Google Cloud
Platform.
So, Emma, how did you do it?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: So we ran
a program called y-cruncher
for four months on
Google Cloud Platform.
And we set up a
class of 25 machines
and we made sure that these
machines ran continuously,
without any shutdown or
reboots for 121 days.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
I mean, that's no easy feat.
120 days, all those
machines running
non-stop, that's kind of
something magical, right?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Yeah.
Well, Google Cloud has a world
of features and mechanisms
to make sure these machines and
software are up and running.
And we sell the modem
systems and other techniques
that we use for our
production servers.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Because,
normally speaking,
it's very difficult to keep one
process running over 121 days,
nonetheless, on 24 machines.
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Right.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So what
inspired you to kind of look
for this many digits of pi?
EMMA HARUKA IWAO: Like
humanity, collectively,
tried to calculate as many
digits of pi as possible,
since like 2000 BC.
And even the first
electronic computer, ENIAC,
was used to calculate
2000 digits of pi.
And ever since then, pi
was used as a benchmark
to measure the performance
and reliability of computers.
And now we use
Google Cloud, so that
means Cloud is capable of doing
this kind of heavy duty work.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That's awesome to see.
Congratulations on
breaking the world record.
Of course, there's more
than just numbers in pi.
We can also use it to make art.
Let's talk to Mathias about
how he managed to do really,
really cool generative art
using all of Emma's work.
Mathias--
MATHIAS PAUMGARTEN: Hi.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Tell
me a little bit more
about what you've done here.
MATHIAS PAUMGARTEN: Right.
So 31 trillion digits
is a huge number, right?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Absolutely.
MATHIAS PAUMGARTEN: Right.
But not only is it
a lot of numbers,
what's really interesting
about pi is also
that the sequence
never repeats itself.
So we thought, what
could we do with this.
So what we came
up with is, we've
made this algorithm that will
turn these sequences of pi
into a visual
representation, essentially.
And this allows people
to find 31 trillion
different visual representations
of pi somewhere within pi.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Can we take a look?
MATHIAS PAUMGARTEN: Absolutely.
So we can jump to
any digit within pi
that we want by just
typing in a random number.
So from that point on it takes
the next several thousand
digits of pi, them being
unique within there,
and then generates a piece of
art out of this, essentially.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So if anyone
else is here, they can come by,
they can change up the
numbers, and they'll
see different
artwork because it's
unique sets of pi patterns.
MATHIAS PAUMGARTEN: Exactly.
So someone could come by,
say they type in their phone
numbers, or like maybe
their birthday, the birthday
of their spouse, or whatnot.
And type this in
and then essentially
get a unique representation
of that number within pi.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Very, very cool.
This is just one of the
many cool experiments
that we have here
at the DevZone.
So hopefully the people here can
come check it out and see all
the cool work that we've done.
[MUSIC PLAYING]